current secretary of transportation and
former
indiana mayor uh pete buddha judge i am
not mayor of indiana uh what was it
south
south bend indiana i believe he was the
mayor of a pete budej
had to put a stop once and for all
to the absurd and ridiculous talking
points about joe biden's infrastructure
bill
having to explain to abc's george
stephanopoulos
humans need water to live which is why
plumbing is part of infrastructure
having to explain mayor pete did to fox
hosts
that electricity is now important enough
to homo sapiens
that spending money on the grid as part
of infrastructure
makes sense and if you haven't heard the
bad faith
and or ignorant responses to biden's
infrastructure bill
they have essentially been one of two
things some people
on the right have reacted to biden's
infrastructure bill
with the typical oh it's too expensive
we can't afford it what about the debt
what about the deficit type responses
that they never give when they're
talking about a republican president
going to war
never those are never concerns when a
republican president wants to go to war
then there's a lot of stuff like this
isn't
really infrastructure spending it's
something else here's an example
south dakota governor christie gnome
said
lots of this stuff isn't infrastructure
it's money for
housing and pipes on a call with the
white house today with all the governors
talking about the specifics of this
package
and i was shocked by how much doesn't go
into infrastructure
it goes into research and development it
goes into housing and
pipes and different initiatives green
energy
and it really is not an honest
conversation we're having
so she takes issue with research
how does she imagine we would improve
infrastructure without doing research i
don't know
every infrastructure advancement in
human history
came thanks to the research that was
done before it when we replace
one type of electric grid with another
it's because somewhere in the middle
there research was done
when we improve the way that we build
bridges
it's because sometime in the interim
research was done
this is like when there's a hurricane
and the relief bill
includes money to figure out how can we
mitigate this being so bad the next time
there's
another hurricane and republicans say
some of that money is not really for
relief right well it's money so that
next time it doesn't do as much damage
by improving
infrastructure or whatever else needs to
be done and of course
pipes water that's infrastructure so
here is mayor pete
boot edge edge on abc over the weekend
explaining to george stephanopoulos
you know humans need water to live which
is why plumbing is part of this
that only about five percent of this
bill goes for traditional roads and
bridges you've got
20 care giving for the elderly about 13
for investments in in like the green new
deal so why not focus on that
traditional core
infrastructure well let's be clear
there's a lot more than uh roads and
bridges uh that are part of
infrastructure
i i heard the the governor of south
dakota recently saying this is an
infrastructure it's got money for pipes
well
we believe that pipes are infrastructure
because you need water to live and too
many families now
live with the threat of lead poisoning
that's absolutely infrastructure
so there's that and then on fox news
here are bill hammer
and dana perino asking mayor pete but
but
but but but secretary there's all this
spending on non-infrastructure stuff
take a listen
we crunch the numbers we find that 5.5
percent
of the two trillion dollar well five
point six
of the two trillion dollar proposal is
only dedicated to roads and bridges
why is that well we're talking about
roads and bridges we're talking about
rail and transit we're talking about
airports and ports as you mentioned
we're talking about things like the grid
i don't know why anybody would say
it's a mistake to invest in the grid
after what we just witnessed
in texas we saw u.s citizens living in
texas
melting snow in their bathtubs to be
able to flush their toilets in the
united states of america
that is unacceptable so yes
infrastructure includes energy
infrastructure
you know what else is part of
infrastructure now broadband i'm proud
of the fact even though it's a little
outside my lane on the transportation
side
i'm proud of the fact that we're going
to finally get broadband out to every
american because we know
especially in rural areas how much
that's cutting people off from
opportunity
good infrastructure planning is always
about looking to the future why are they
obsessed with this idea that
only roads and bridges count as
infrastructure the electrical grid
green energy plumbing high speed
internet
this is all infrastructure and for some
of the less ignorant conservatives
there's a bad faith aspect here um
i there's an analogy here to the postal
service
why is it that republicans want to
kneecap the postal service
it's because they don't want the
government in the business of delivering
mail
now the postal service is a sort of
pseudo government entity but the point
is
conservatives want the postal service
gone so that for-profit companies like
dhl fedex and ups will get more market
share that you know
there's a philosophical underpinning to
that
similarly with this infrastructure thing
many right-wingers
see anything the government gets
involved in
as a loss for private industry now the
reality is that it's misguided
when we talk about the government doing
infrastructure this
is not you know i know they love to say
it is but
the us is not a communist country where
most construction work is done by
government-owned
companies most of the infrastructure
work will be done by private companies
they will be hired by the government yes
uh but it's still going to be work that
goes out to private companies so that's
one group
then you have people who just don't know
what's going on they have like they
don't understand the world
around them and they think that uh you
know the electrical grid really isn't
part of infrastructure and it's
disturbing that mayor pete
has to even explain this stuff to people
who you would imagine
know about it the commons we all benefit
from it and we help maintain it either
directly or through tax money clean
water air
access to electricity in some places
increasingly
broadband these are just examples and of
course there is
nothing more economically
stimulative than great infrastructure
better airports
so that people more easily and eagerly
come to the united states to do business
have you seen airports in other parts of
the world short of
you know there's a few terminals at a
few airports in the united states
that are at the caliber of what global
airports are
but by and large our airports are put to
shame by airports in other countries
who will go to stores if the roads are
unusable or the bridges are unsafe
this is economically stimulative for the
very private businesses that republicans
claim to prioritize and want to support
it's in a sense a really shrewd business
move it's called
cost externalization you're a business
you're able to externalize
a bunch of costs for infrastructure
that you benefit from they're building
the infrastructure so that customers can
go and do business with you
with other people's tax money like you
would think they would absolutely love
it
republicans should love it but anytime
government is quote spending money
they just reflexively are against it
anytime it's proposed by democrats
they reflexively are against it remember
democrats voted for both of trump's
covet stimulus bills why because even
though it was trump it was the right
thing to do
yeah it wasn't big enough it was too
slow okay flip it
republicans all of a sudden don't want
coveted stimulus
when it's democrats controlling the
house senate and the white house these
people are pathetic
these people are pathetic many so-called
healthy snacks don't taste that great
they don't fill you up
they don't satisfy a craving which is
why you should check out our sponsor
monk pack and their keto nut and
seed bars delicious sweet snacks
with only a gram of sugar or less two to
three grams of net carbs
and just 150 calories perfect for the
keto or low carb diet
or anybody who just generally tries to
eat a low sugar diet
like me i love the monk pack keto nut
and seed bars
just a great balance of sweet and salty
soft and chewy but with a nice
crunch from the nuts and seeds you can
get
great flavors like caramel not caramel
come on guys
caramel sea salt sea salt dark chocolate
peanut butter dark chocolate that's my
personal favorite they'll give you
all of your money back if you don't love
it go to monkpack.com the link is down
below and you'll get 20
off any of their products when you use
the coupon code
pacman